I mean athletically Logan's a lot more
athletic as far as legit competition
Dylan's way more qualified you look at
you know four-time world champion
Jiu-Jitsu as a brown belt uh compet at
black belt compet in ADCC you know he's
a lot more accomplished but just
Jiu-Jitsu he's never been known as a
striker then you look at Logan obviously
been in bigger entertainment spectacles
as far as you know he did fight Floyd
Mayweather who's smaller boxer but
that's a lot of pressure uh the does WWE
which isn't real but it's still an
athletic event he did really good and
there's a lot of eyeballs you tend to
side towards Logan on this right I would
yeah I find myself rooting for Dylan a
little bit just because all the [__]
he's been through you see you know he
he's sober now there's a good person in
there I mean if you're putting money on
it you're putting it on Logan right no
cuz the odds 450 for Logan plus 330 for
Dylan